tonight the Deputy Prime Minister coming
out of number 10. Mr Rob are you
confident you'll be clear of the
allegations sir
questions about his appoint
inter-cabinet looming large
his boss promised to lead a government
of integrity and accountability but it
sackings and slees that have dominated
his first hundred days Mr sunac sit in
side by side with his Deputy both
checking their notes as labor targeted
its attack on allegations around Dominic
Robb's Behavior but the last pout the
Deputy Prime Minister was facing 24
separate allegations of bullying how
would he feel if one of his friends or
relatives was being forced to work for a
bully simply because the man at the top
was too weak to do anything about it
trying to shake it off but this pm at
only his 11th pm queues and already on
to defending a fourth cabinet Minister's
conduct at this dispatch box when I was
made aware of former complaints I
instructed a leading independent KC to
conduct an investigation that
investigation into eight formal
complaints of bullying ongoing another
into the tax Affairs of the formatory
chair Nadeem zahawi concluded but the
stain of Tory sleaze still there the
Tory party's addiction to sleaze and
Scandal has done huge damage to this
country and the cost of the public keeps
adding up
today a show of unity from the two
Leading Men in government sit inside by
side but none of this is comfortable for
the Prime Minister now number 10 is
clear that officials never advise Mr
sunac against appointing Mr Rob nor were
there any formal complaints ahead of Mr
Rob being made Deputy Prime Minister but
I've been told that the Prime Minister
was personally informed about Mr Robbs
to quote my source unacceptable Behavior
weeks before rishisuna became prime
minister and put Mr Rob into his cabinet
now political editor Beth Rigby a source
telling her today that this summer so
before he was prime minister before he
appointed Dominic arrived his cabinet he
was made aware of concerns around
Dominic raab's conduct what did Rishi
sunak know
it wasn't the case that the Prime
Minister received any formal complaints
before this started however they did
emerge subsequently and that's why he's
taken it very seriously but what Mr
sunac knew and when will weigh on number
10 as the formal investigation into Mr
Rob drags on and drags in his boss Beth
Rigby Sky News in Westminster